all right welcome everybody my name is
Rowan k'tau during the day I worked for
Wikipedia and we're awesome and we're
hiring you should check out our booth at
Union Station but at night I volunteer
in this project to bring open-source
software to elections so that's what I'm
going to talk about today and I hope
this clicker works so I should have set
screen mirroring for this so why I'm
gonna talk in four acts here about what
an open-source voting system is and why
you might use one so first I'll talk
about why you use software for elections
in the first place then second I'll talk
about why open-source is particularly
important for this for this application
thirdly I'll talk about what kind of
open source software is out there in the
world to do election related stuff and
then finally I'll talk about the project
that we're doing in San Francisco and
and what's going on with that so first
I'll back up one step which is why would
you use software fluxions at all like
aren't elections these things that you'd
like do on paper and then people count
them so in November 2016 we had an
election as you might have heard
including in San Francisco where I live
and there is a voter guide that gets
mailed to every person in San Francisco
by the by the city and the introduction
from the director of elections began as
follows
big ballots are back and what does he
mean when he says that he means stuff
like this this is actually not from
November this is from this past June
when we had a special election these are
the local ballot propositions that you
could vote on and we had ballot
propositions abcdefg and Paige and I and
if you thought that was bad that was not
November in November we had a through X
so we we have to vote for like you know
your federal office you're the president
US Senate US House you have state
assembly state Senate state judges you
got a vote for like you know County
Supervisor City College Board BART Board
all that kind of stuff and then you got
your your propositions we love ourselves
some demerit directed ma Christine
California so we had 25
propositions and 17 state white ones and
if you add this all together you could
have up to 52 things to vote for on one
ballots some people had 50 something
with 51 it's sort of depends on where
you live if you did various intersecting
districts that you're in have an
election that you're not in total there
were 60 things being voted on across the
city because you know you've got like
we're in two different house districts
they both are the Russians at the same
time so it's a little bit more that
meant that we had a ballot that was four
pages double-sided so people actually
like sat there and like filled out you
know they sit in the polling place I've
seen it it takes a long time and they go
and fill out the ballot front and back
and then four more times if you were
lucky you only had four pages
double-sided if you were unlucky at a
fifth page and if you add this all up
like four hundred fourteen thousand
people voted in November of 2016 it's
about a hundred it's about 1.8 million
pages of stuff and there's like they're
not like you know letter sized pages
they're like a little bit of pretty long
cards as well so it's a lot it's a lot
of paper it's a lot of data and secondly
another complicating factor that we have
in San Francisco and a few other cities
in California is that we have
rank-choice voting so for certain local
offices like Board of Supervisors and
mayor you can indicate your first second
and third choice and then there's an
algorithm that happens for like you know
if your first choice loses then your
vote goes to your second choice and that
person also loses your vote goes to your
third choice this gets complicated and
it gets more complicated when you have
more votes so for supervisory we have
eleven districts in the city so you
really only have like thirty to forty
thousand votes in high turnout elections
in high turnout districts and you might
get down to like ten to twenty thousand
in lower turnout situations but we had a
mayor's election in June that was highly
contested and it used rank-choice voting
that was two hundred fifty three
thousand votes so it's a lot of data to
deal with and you you're not you can do
this by hand but you're not going to do
this by hand anymore you need to run an
algorithm in a computer to compute this
result and the result end up looking
something like this these were the last
couple of rounds of eliminations so like
you know in in the seventh round Angela
Alioto has a fused vote so she get
eliminated
her votes get redistributed and so on
and so forth the kinds of numbers
involved like you're not going to have
humans like take sixty six thousand and
forty three cards and then like sorting
them into two piles one that's like
thirteen thousand two hundred ten
ballots tall and one that's forty four
thousand seven iron 24-valve style
you're just gonna pull all the data in
the computer and then it will generate
this table until you want so that is a
good reason that you want software and
to review you're dealing with a lot of
data if you have 50-plus items on any
given ballot and you have four hundred
thousand people voting that's twenty
million votes essentially if you break
it down per contest you have to do ranks
or elimination rounds between like as
many as twenty one cannabis because that
happened once and as many as a quarter
million votes that's a lot of processing
you don't wanna do by hand in a computer
can do in seconds you have to input all
that data in a computer somehow which is
why you want to scan your your ballots
and have like computerized
interpretation to devotes because you
also just can't input all that data fast
enough or hire enough people to do that
if it's this much data and other other
advantages is if you use computers for
for voting that the voters interact with
directly you can reduce or eliminate
voter error if if I fill out my ballot
and then I have to feed it into a
scanner the scanner can spit it back out
at me if it notices that I voted twice
for the same thing when I'm not allowed
to if I vote on a touchscreen it can
just refuse to let me enter votes that
are invalid right so you can you can
vastly reduce a number of votes that get
rejected completely because they're
invalid for some reason because the
system will just not let you make the
mistake or will warn you against it and
finally not everyone can like read the
size of the font that is printed in the
ballot or like C at all so if you have a
touchscreen device where you can blow up
the font if you can attach headphones to
it and like have the ballot read out to
you and you can push the button to make
your selection those are really great
features that help a lot more people
vote so there's good reasons to use
software but as we've all heard software
can also be dangerous so I'll briefly go
through a couple of voting systems and
then linger on one
then go on to sort of the next topic of
why we want to use open source software
for this so you can do hand count at
paper ballot you could do the
old-fashioned way I like the way that we
used to do in days if you are before
computers everyone fills out of a land
then people go and sit down and count
everything by hand some countries still
do this they have hints they don't have
like fifty two things on one piece of
papers account but there were countries
that went back to this after after some
of the events of 2016 or never left it
at all you can do what we do in San
Francisco is people vote on paper in
general and then they go through a
scanner and the scanner decides what
that means
there's also these what is called direct
recording voting machines and these are
things with levers you've got this
expression of like pulling a lever for
this candidate right and it's because
some of the eastern states had these
machines where you your voter walked up
to a machine and you had like a lever
for each candidate you pull the lever
and then it inside the machine there's a
counter it gets incremented for the
candidate and then at the end of the day
you can sort of open the Machine up and
look at what the counters say this is
all mechanical was not electronic so
that used to exist and then in in the
early 2000s we saw the rise of the
direct record electronic voting machines
which is basically the computerized
version of that so typically like
touchscreen machines where you like
enter your choice and it just says thank
you for voting and there's like a
counter inside the machine like a
variable right that counts how many
votes each candidate received and in the
end of the day you ask the machine
what's the result and it gives you
numbers so it is hopefully obvious that
this is if you do this without a
terrible paper trail it is a terrible
terrible idea and you should not do it
it's super unsafe and unaudible even if
the software was somehow like open
source which it's not let's be honest
there is no way to audit the results and
this is the this is an issue with like
the lever of machines right you can't go
back and like look at every vote because
their votes never exist in a paper with
these systems you can check if you added
up the results from all the precincts
correctly but you can't check if you
you know you can't double-check if
people actually voted the way they did
because you all you have is what the
computer tells you so 14 states still
use this somewhere there are five states
that use these machines statewide
Georgia is actually getting sued over
this where a group is demanding paper
ballots and the judge seems to basically
agree with them except also believe that
it's too late now to switch for November
but they're they're hopefully going to
be forced to switch to paper ballots
soon for the next election and in many
European countries this was tried in the
early thousands as well and then the end
of being banned either legislatively or
through court cases someone actually
sued over this in Germany and the whole
concept of electronic voting was just
found unconstitutional
so we're far away's from that but that
is a site that is a site note this is
super insecure if you live in one of
these states like you know content lis
representatives and tell them to fix the
situation yeah so to use software safely
you want to use paper ballots you want
to audit everything because open-source
or not you can't trust the software
interpreted everything correctly but
that's why you have the paper so in
California for example we have a
requirement that 1% of all the polling
places get their ballots audited so you
open up the boxes you hand counts all
the ballots for a polling place which is
only a couple hundred so doesn't take
that much time and you compare it to the
Machine results and then if that if that
matches you trust that it also went okay
elsewhere there's an emerging technology
called risk limiting the audits that I
will get into later where you use
statistical methods to determine whether
things went right and another great
thing that you can do that that we are
doing some of us publishing data so in
San Francisco for example with our
rank-choice voting system we publish a
database that is essentially like a row
for every vote that was cast with the
first second and third choice for that
that person made and then any member of
the public can download the database
write their own code to do the
rank-choice voting algorithm and verify
that the results was correct that the
city did the redistributions of votes
correctly and what we're hoping will
happen in the future and what's sort of
emerging as well as
the idea of publishing images of every
valve that was scanned some of the newer
scanners have technology to do that and
then you can write your own like you
know optical recognition software to
recognize what each pallet is and see if
you get the same result as the
government did so that's sort of where
that field was headed so in San
Francisco we use a system that is not
open-source surprise surprise we use a
proprietary system by a company called
Dominion which was since acquired by
Sequoia because there's a lot of
consolidation happening in that market
people mark babe Mac BIOS by hand they
are they then feed them into a scanner
and they're scanned immediately when
they cast them we do have direct
recording electronic machines for
accessible voting so the people that
need to like wear a headset and have
their about sort of listen to the ballot
and push a button when their choice
comes up that uses director directly a
recording machine but that has a paper
trail and because of like weird
technicalities for how this was
certified we're actually required to
then transcribe this paper trail onto
ballots and feed it into the scanners
which is stupid but it's how this works
in its loft safer and a lot of our
people vote by mail so those those
ballots get scanned as well at a central
location and so this is what that looks
like I think this image got rotated
wrong or something it's very blurry in
any case but this is the hands of a
person feeding a ballot into a scanner
and this is sort of the scanner reads
the ballot and then it puts it into a
box and a basket to get some tea at the
end of the day all right so the kinds of
things that you need to build a system
like this right because we want to build
this we just want to build it with
open-source software is you need an
accessible device and that's that's the
hardest part you need you need a thing
and software with like you know
headphones and a big push button and
magnification and and all that kind of
stuff you need a balla scanner that you
put at your polling places that voters
will feed ballots in to you and you need
a central valve scanner for your vote by
mail ballots where you can just like put
stacks of ballots in and they'll just
like go through them at high volume like
I think the scanners that we currently
have are like 240 ballots per minute or
something so like 4 per sec
it's really impressive to watch them
just fly through so that's the kind of
hardware that you need to need to work
with and then the software components
that you need is you need software to
lay out ballots like sort of like
desktop publishing kind of stuff but you
need that not only because you need to
design the ballots and send them to a
printer but also because when the
ballots come back into the scanner you
need to know what's where like if if a
voter marked a circle or in San
Francisco they connect arrows somewhere
on the page you need to know what that
location on the page means which contest
is that which candidate is that you need
software to obviously scan the ballots
and interpret them which depends on that
you need something called ballot
adjudication which is where if the
computer can't make a confident
interpretation can't make a decision on
how to interpret the ballot you need a
workflow to take that image and surface
it to a human who is asked to interpret
it and this shouldn't happen very often
but for the cases where the computer
doesn't know what to do you should be
able to do that you should be able to
take that image and say like help I
don't know what to do decide this for me
you need software to do what's called
tabulation which is really just like
adding everything up which is extremely
easy except when you have the rank
choice situation that I explained
earlier where you actually have to write
an algorithm with a bunch of edge cases
and be very careful and you want to do
results reporting like the the table
that I just showed you with the
different redistributions the various
formats that we publish election results
on the website there's a letter that the
director of Elections needs to sign to
officially certify the election you want
to be able to generate all those things
and for for public consumption and then
finally you want to have some software
features to assist you in audits and
that's something that all talk about in
a minute so going towards more like why
we want to use open source software
proprietary software has all the
classical problems that you might have
heard of it is expensive in San
Francisco we spent 10 million dollars to
buy this system and cleaning the
hardware and then we spend on average
about a million a year to license it and
there's some of these are ongoing
license costs some are these are per
election costs so this is an expensive
year because we have two elections and
20
tene the you know the source code is
secret we don't know the code that runs
our election process and the city
government doesn't even know that
because it's proprietary to the vendor
and they're not telling anybody if you
want to change your voting system for
some reason you're screwed because you
can't unless you can convince your
vendor which is like one of three
players in the market to implement your
thing which will either take vast sums
of money or it will not be available
the fact that we use rank-choice voting
greatly limits our procurement to
because not all voting system vendors
even support that so that that that is
that leads you to vendor lock-in it's
really hard to switch vendors because
you have to get like new equipment and
new everything often have it to get a
new ballot design which means that the
public just noticed that you switched
voting systems which ideally they
shouldn't and if any of you all have
paid attention to the coverage of this
year's Def Con or last year's Def Con or
the year before you will have seen
headlines like you know 11 year old
cracks voting system or like you know
all these voting machines that they
bought on eBay and then like hacked
within 30 minutes right there is there's
lots of insecure software running on
these things and lots of ways that they
are compromised and the vendors don't
carry that much but you know we do see
trying to go to next fight here we go so
open source is somewhat uniquely
important here because election software
is critical infrastructure for the
functioning of our society elections are
a critical process and without trust and
election integrity we don't really have
the society that we want to have so a
lot of places in the United States have
antiquated voting technology that they
can't afford to replace and part of that
is because of the history behind it is
when we had all the hanging chads
scandals in Florida in 2000 the
government was like we must solve this
problem so they gave States a ton of
money in 2002 under the help America
Vote Act to get these fancy new machines
and get these touchscreen devices that
we would never have an ambiguous ballad
ever again and then the money stopped
coming so now everyone's got their
machines for two thousand two and
they're getting old and needs
place and now there's no money for them
until you know unless and until the
federal government comes up with another
infusion of cash which good luck getting
it from this government everyone's going
to be stuck with old machines and
they're not gonna have the money to buy
new ones so it's also important to it's
important to have high quality software
and and hardware and it's important to
reduce the cost so the practical
advantages that you have here of using
open-source for this is that across -
over time and across jurisdictions is
then it ends up being cheaper because
the business model of these vendors is
one the fact that it's a small market
but also the fact that they can sell the
same product to multiple people for the
same price because they're not allowed
to share so they sold the same thing
that you're selling to us for ten
million dollars and then a million a
year they're also selling to neighboring
San Mateo County for ten million dollars
and 1 million a year or whatever they're
paying because we might not know that so
if you develop an open-source system
that everyone then shares the the
authority it develops it bears a lot of
the costs and that will I mean honestly
that will probably cost you more than
ten million dollars but you then you
have it and then it's much cheaper to
redeploy somewhere else not everyone
keeps paying for the same thing over and
over and there's no one making a profit
except the people that originally built
it so and on top of that if you want to
innovate or change things like if you're
a jurisdiction that wants to try some
new sort of voting system like maybe you
want to do like multi-member rank choice
voting which like virtually no one in
the u.s. is doing right now you are not
dependent Your Honor the mercy of one of
these three big companies to implement
it for you
you can do it yourself or you can hire
people to do it yourself they need not
be the same people that developed the
original system you have a lot more
flexibility a lot more space for
innovation and ends up being cheaper
overall it's also a great reason why we
need state or federal funding for this
because you have a tragedy of the
Commons problem it doesn't necessarily
make sense for one county like San
Francisco to develop a system like this
if we're gonna bearable costs and end up
basically putting more money into it
then we get value out of it but then
everyone else gets value out of it so
that's that's a great argument for
sharing the cost that's why we should
get state funding for this which we've
tried to do it would be great to get
federal funding
but it's not going to happen until 2020
at least so moving on I'll briefly touch
on some of the other open-source
software
efforts that are that have gone on in
this space so there is a project called
Prime 3 which is written by some
professor in Florida University and
picked up by the state of New Hampshire
so this is a GPL project that you can
find on github or at least prime 3 is
one for all is a name that New Hampshire
branded everything with and they they
took it in the add of some things and
this is an accessible voting system so
you can buy some hardware like off the
shelf you can just like go on Amazon and
buy like a tablet and a printer and a
keyboard and a headphones and hook it
all Huck it all up together put the
software in a tablet and then you have a
device that people with disabilities can
use to to vote but what this does is it
ends up printing a ballot so it doesn't
actually do any of the vote counting
where I need sort of the critical path
parts of the voting process what this
all this lets you do which is important
but not everything that you need to do
is let a blind person come in and use an
audio interface to print a ballot and
there's also cool sort of non disabled
person features like you can have an app
that you make your selections on ahead
of time then it generates a QR code on
your phone you scan the QR codes in the
machine and then your ballot comes out
of the printer so these are some cool
applications that they're playing with
up in New Hampshire and this is what it
looks like this is a still from one of
their training videos from the New
Hampshire's from New Hampshire's office
in the Secretary of State and that's
like you know it's a tablet and a
keyboard with big with like big print
letters and then the gray box behind the
lady's arm is a is a printer and what
she's holding in her hand is headphones
you just buy this equipment like at Best
Buy or on Amazon or whatever you put the
software on it and you have your you
have your accessible voting set up is
the idea another really cool software
package that's been developed recently
is something called Colorado r-la so I
talked earlier about audits and how in
California we have the simplistic
approach of you randomly select one
percent of all the polling places you
audit them
but somewhat a professor at UC Berkeley
developed a more advanced method for
doing this with statistical methods
there it's called risk limiting audits
and this software was built to
facilitate that so a company called free
and fair which builds open-source
election software developed this was
commissioned by Colorado to develop this
last year it's released under a GPL and
the first phase has been used in an
election in Colorado already and a
second phase and it works and so this is
the circle method that you can use to
verify whether your scanners are
counting things correctly and arguably
this is the most important step of it
right like it doesn't it doesn't really
matter what you do to obtain the result
as long as you can prove that result is
right so the way this works real quick
is that you get your software to
interpret your ballots you assign an ID
to every ballot and you link the
software's interpretation of the ballot
to the valid ID and then you just have
like a giant database of like this
ballot ID is a vote for this person then
you randomly select a couple like a
hundred or so ballot II's and you tell
the people to go find those ballots
which might mean that they have to call
someone up in a remote corner of
Colorado which is why you need software
to coordinating all this stuff but you
say find the ballot with this number
they find it a human looks at it and
says I think this is a vote for
candidate X and then you look at your
database to see if it's actually you
vote for candidate X if this matches
enough times then pretty quickly but
only examining like a couple hundred or
maybe a couple thousand ballots
depending on how close the election was
you can get to the point where you have
95% or 99% certainty that you call the
correct winner because especially if the
margin was really big the errors have
nowhere to hide right you need to be
finding errors otherwise it's
statistically extremely unlikely if your
results wrong so there this software
facilitates that and helps them with a
lot of logistics of like tracking all
these ballots and like tracking down
which County owns the ballot that with
that number and so forth other projects
that have that have happened and sort of
failed for various definitions have
failed one is in Travis County in Texas
which is where us
is at a project called star vote which
was a design for a full voting system
and election management system and
everything everything that you would
want to run an election they were
somewhat waffling on whether they
weren't gonna release it as open source
but they said they intended to and they
abandoned it last year because they
couldn't get someone to bid on the
entire project and they said that no
combination of bids that they got would
have satisfied everything and I think
that there are some mistakes that they
made with the way that they procured it
and they they sort of designed
everything up front but that failed and
Los Angeles County has this project
called V SAP which is a fool the user
called voter centered redesign of like
everything the software and the hardware
in the process on all of it and they
they commissioned that for 282 million
dollars which is a lot of money and the
system is now been certified it will
count Mille votes in November 2018 in
the upcoming election and in 2020
they're switching to a semi all
vote-by-mail system so then it will
count all ballots this has been
advertised as open source and in fact
the press release when it was certified
last month said like first open source
system certified so we did a public
records requests for the source code and
they denied it there there's some stuff
in the contract is open we found that
and there's some stuff in there that LA
County research reserves the right to
publish it open source if they want to
but it sounds like the best that we
could possibly hope for is quote-unquote
disclosed source where we will be able
to see it but not reuse it so it's not
it's trying to use this open source
language from time to time but it's not
really so the San Francisco projects is
the only one ongoing that hasn't been
abandoned that would actually that would
develop a system there's actually open
source and can be reused by other
jurisdictions so our goals are to have
the project be open source from the
start like we think it should be gplv3
but whatever it is like the first thing
in the repository should be a license
file that explains what the license is
it should be developed in the open it
should work the way that open-source
projects actually work in the real world
not like we're going to develop this and
then maybe we're going to make it open
source later but no promises we want it
we want a commitment up front
we want it to use off-the-shelf hardware
as much as possible so stuff that you
can buy on Amazon or FS buy you want the
documentation to be openly licensed and
we want as I said before we want it to
be cheap and easy to reuse our
neighboring counties and other places at
least in California if not elsewhere in
the nation should be able to just pick
it pick this up buy their own hardware
and run with it
that should be easy enough should be
cheap and we're hoping to be able to set
a model for California and for the US
and we hope that because we're San
Francisco where we have no shortage of
you know tech companies and tech talent
that the that this should be possible
right and that if anyone can do it
hopefully it's us so so we're hoping to
make it happen
so there's a long history of advocacy
there where in 2005 people started
talking about this when some of the
first scandals came up about electronic
voting machines that have been rolled
out about three years prior and then
there's this whole history of
bureaucracy where it takes about seven
years to go from like establishing a
task force to like getting the Election
Commission to agree this is something
that we should do but from there it's
starting to move a little bit a little
bit we got a little bit of money to do a
planning phase and last year a technical
advisory committee was formed which I
sit on that's that's why I'm here that's
how I fit into this where we've got some
some tech people from around the Bay
Area together to advise the city
government and how they should go about
this project because the people that run
elections in San Francisco and OH are
people who know about election is not
necessarily people who know about
software so in 2018 we didn't get as
much money budgeted for this as we want
it we had hopes for four million dollars
we've got 1.7 million dollars over two
years allocated to development of this
project so it's really exciting and so
the the next steps on that are actually
that the city is gonna hire a project
manager but more about that in a bit
this project has been supported by a lot
of organizations and this is a very
hilarious slide to me because it's like
one third of it as tech companies that
people in this room recognized like
github and like you know organizations
like the open source initiative and then
there's like you know the San Francisco
Democratic Party and like the Harvey
Milk LGBT Democratic Club and then
there's other advocacy organ
like a national election defense
coalition which like most people only
know that like one-third of these people
exist in there a different third for
every person so we've got like an
eclectic coalition of people behind this
and we've got some nice press coverage
about it but it's kind of an out of this
slide because I'm trying to find the
date on this this is November 26 2015 so
I should update this this slide it's
kind of an old headline and more but
more recently this summer the civil
grand jury released a report about open
stars voting in San Francisco where they
made some good recommendations and how
we can move this forward so there's some
attention coming to this and as I said
there is now some dollars behind it as
well which is exciting so the the first
iteration that we're proposing here
because you should develop this
iteratively that's how things work in
the real open-source software world is
start with vote-by-mail ballots San
Franciscans love to vote by mail in the
November 2016 election 63% of our votes
were cast by mail and in this past June
it was almost 65 percent and I think
that's just going to keep going up and
we'll hit 2/3 before 2020 so if you're
able to do vote by mail ballots only
you're actually covering like the vast
majority of ballots already it's it is
the predominant use case so to do that
you need surprisingly little you need
hardware and software for a scanner and
in particular need hardware for a
high-volume scanner you need you know
software for layout and coding and
tabulation and results reporting and
some auditing and batch management stuff
and supporting that I'm not going to
talk about but you need basically the
basics to make sure that you can
interpret and count votes but the appeal
of this is that you only need to roll
this out on about four to six devices
instead of like 600 devices because
you're not doing polling places and
you're 46 devices are going to be in the
basement of City Hall operated by a
select group of trained people rather
than like be located in random parking
garages where they're going to be
operated by everyday people and just
literally random voters would walk in so
it's a lot easier to get this kind of
stuff right where you can where you can
train the people you only need to buy a
couple of ice
you don't need to have like hundreds of
devices that you need to track
throughout the city I need to be
completely foolproof so this is gonna be
easier to phase in except despite then
then just like polling place scanners is
especially going to be easier than
accessible devices because accessibility
is hard people have all sorts of issues
disability issues that you never
imagined and it's really hard to get
that kind of stuff right and in addition
to that we want to do modular
procurement as well we want to be able
to like put out different parts of this
system to different vendors and and
integrate it together later we want to
be able to switch vendors halfway
through if we're not happy so by
building the system and pieces you're
also doing that and with this you can
sort of prove that the system works by
spending like you know ten percent of
your money on sixty four percent of your
use case so that's that's a great
trade-off we think so currently we have
our technical advisory committee we have
our monthly meetings and we develop
recommendations but our recommendations
document is actually on github because
we practice what we preach we eat our
own dog food etc so you too can submit a
poor request to our recommendations
document if you think something should
be in there and we welcome that there
was a feasibility study that was
commissioned last year that came back
earlier this year with a super flot
report that we've shot full of holes
that had outrageous cost estimates which
we're now trying to disprove by making
some proofs of concept ourselves
committing convincing government people
to actually spine money as hard
especially if they see scary numbers but
we got 1.7 million dollars in the city
budget as I said for the 2018 2020
budget so we've got something to move
forward with and the city is now
recruiting to hire a project manager for
this project and hopefully that's one of
you there was also some proposals for
getting state matching funds from the
state of California for this project but
that unfortunately had died but
nevertheless the city has put some of
its own money to that so that's that's
been good and you too can help us make
this make us can help us make this a
reality you can support us by signing up
as
which I will have sheets where you can
put down your email address and get our
get our newsletter and everything you
can follow s of Oakland voting on
Twitter for for updates and also because
having more followers makes us look good
because that's the way things work you
can contribute by submitting pull
requests to our recommendations at OS
VTAC that could have that i/o and you
can apply to be the project manager
working for the city of San Francisco
too to help make this project a reality
or if you don't want to do that you can
encourage your friends to do so so a
bitly slash voting job we have that job
description up and I hope that we can
get someone someone good in that
position because that'll be really
important and finally if you're not in
San Francisco you can advocate for this
locally you can build support in your
county or in your state
talk to your elected officials and your
election administrators and try to get
them to see that this is important and
at collaborating on software that we can
all use that is not and not owned by
companies to run our elections is
important so that's all I got my
contacts atop of the slide if you want
to get in touch with me about this and
then as I said apply for the apply for
the project manager job spread the word
about it follow us on Twitter and our
recommendation document is on that URL
and more information is there as well
and you too can submit poor request to
it so thank you very much for listening
and I hope you found this exciting
[Applause]